In this exercise, you'll start with a different procedural texture. It works
fine, but I want you to know about an important debugging technique. Since you
can't put break points inside a shader, it's hard to know what's going on. The
answer is to send various shader computations to the screen itself. In other
words, instead of putting your final result into GL_FRAGColor, put these other
intermediate values. In fact, you have three whole color channels to use and
view on the screen. Your task is to send the following program values, diffuse,
ugain alpha, and attenuation to each of these channels. All three of these
values is in the proper range of zero to one, so need no adjustment. Here's
what things will look like when you're done. Under material control in the user
interface is a slider called gain alpha. So, I think it will change the green
channel to match the value selected. One bit to notice in the code is that
there's a sub routine called compute bias. It's fine to use sub routines inside
shaders, and they have a C language type of interface.